und impfdosen bis zum jahresende mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit erreichen und
die impfkampagne sollte dann so ist auch
die verabredung des heutigen tages auch
darüber hinaus auf hochtouren weiter
laufen an dieser stelle noch einmal ein
ganz herzlicher dank an alle menschen
die das möglich machen sie leisten einen
großen dienst in unserem land und ihren
mitmenschen wir wollen bis ende januar
so ist die verabredung weitere 30
millionen impfungen
erreichen und deshalb muss das tempo bei
dieser impfkampagne weiter hoch bleiben
es geht darum dass wir eben alle auch
wenn wir uns freuen auf die begegnung
mit familien mit freunden sehr sehr
verantwortungsvoll und überlegen wie
können wir unsere kontakte einschränken
wenn man sich trifft möglichst eben das
schützen das testen das impfen in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen und es ist ganz
klar dass angesichts dieser lage wir
auch uns keine pause erlauben können was
das impfen angeht die impfkampagne muss
auch über die feiertage weiter laufen
mit nur sehr geringen
runter fahrenden aspekten vielleicht am
heiligabend am ersten feiertag aber auch
wir in berlin haben uns natürlich
genauso wie alle anderen bundesländer
ganz klar das ziel gesetzt diese tage
weiter zu nutzen wir sind darauf
angewiesen dass viele dabei mithelfen
sowohl die hausärzte die auch zwischen
den jahren mithelfen beim impfen als
auch unsere impfzentren die mobilen im
teams und auch die kreativen aktionen an
besonders an den bildschirmen verfolgen
können die gebärdendolmetscherin
frühlingswärme live in die
bundespressekonferenz dort haben sich
lothar wieler chef des robert koch
institut und karl lauterbach eingefunden
der bundesgesundheitsminister mit ihrer
gemeinsamen
die bundespressekonferenz ganz herzlich
bedanken
dass wir diese gelegenheit haben wir
kurz auf die
auslage pandemie entwicklung zu sprechen
kommen aus der perspektive der
bundesregierung wir sind in einer
situation wo es uns gelingt die welle
mit der data variante
langsam aber sicher gut in den griff zu
bekommen wir haben sinkende fallzahlen
die maßnahmen die ergriffen worden sind
wirken sie wirken auch nachhaltig und
das hat auch gott sei dank eine
entlastende wirkung auf die belastung
der krankenhäuser aber auf die
intensivstation
nichtsdestotrotz also müssen wir mit
einer fünften welle jetzt sicher rechnen
gern in deutschland mittlerweile so
viele comic unfälle auf der grundlage
von sogenannten waren varianten pcs die
wir durchführen aber auch so wählens
also gc aus dass wir davon ausgehen
müssen dass sich die omikron welle in
deutschland nicht mehr verhindern lässt
und das ja auch in deutschland ankommen
gehört darauf bereiten wir uns derzeit
intensiv vor gestern hat die
bundesregierung zusammen mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder
entsprechende beschlüsse gefasst die
wesentlich auch also auf vorarbeiten aus
meinem haus und vorarbeiten des
expertenrates zurückgegangen sind hier
ist von großer bedeutung dass wir
gesehen haben dass die also varianz der
also in fallzahlen der infektionen in
deutschland also sehr breit ist das haus
in der woche infizieren sich dort nicht
weniger das haus am wochenende das hat
dazu geführt dass wir clubs und
diskotheken ab jetzt schließen werden
wir haben darüber hinaus also maßnahmen
ergriffen die die kontakte reduzieren da
insbesondere eben also die zahl
derjenigen die sich treffen können auch
geimpfte und genesene reduziert auf 10
in den raum wie draußen wir rechnen
damit dass das also die zahl der
neuinfektionen senken wird aber
wichtiger noch also unser wichtigster
baustein unserer wichtigster bestandteil
der bekämpfung der vor uns liegende
nockenwelle liegt darin dass wir eine
besonders offensive booster kampagne
fahren wie sich erinnern habe ich das
schon vorgetragen in meiner ersten
bundestagsrede zum thema und das ist die
strategie unseres hauses ist es ganz
klar dass an der booster strategie die
mikrowelle nicht ganz verhindern kann
aber sie ist das wichtigste was man tun
kann um zu verhindern dass sehr viele
menschen schwer erkranken wir wissen
mittlerweile aus dem studien und dass
die booster impfungen gut wirken zur
vermeidung von ansteckungen aber auch
von schweren verläufen bei der omicron
variante wir gehen davon aus dass die
wirksamkeit schon eine woche nach der
booster impfung einsetzt also nicht wie
nach der zweiten impfung werden
typischerweise zwei wochen nach der
impfung die wirkung haben sehen wir hier
schon eine woche nach der booster
impfung an der deutliche wirkung das ist
sehr bedeutsam und wir sehen auch in den
studien vorliegen das die wirksamkeit
der booster impfung irgendwo zwischen 70
und 80 prozent liegt was die
symptomatische infektion angeht
wahrscheinlich ist der schutz vor
schwere erkrankung sehr hoch hier wurde
ich von einem schutz ausgehen der
deutlich über 90 prozent liegt es könnte
sein dass also nach der booster impfung
schwere fälle durch die omikron variante
einer also seltenheit sind dass es zu
mir zumindest die arbeitshypothese mit
der wir arbeiten auf jeden fall gehen
wir mit einem schutzfaktor aus der über
90 prozent liegt die booster außerdem
werden wir durchführen im wesentlichen
mit dem impfstoff moderner zum baden ist
dass der impfstoff den die derzeit
verfügbar haben haben für die jetzt
zweiter wäre der booster impfung haben
wir 30 millionen dosen von moderner zur
verfügung wir haben bisher 27 millionen
menschen mit einer buße schon versehen
also wir haben eine gute booster impfung
kampagne bisher gefahren bin
wahrscheinlich bis weihnachten die 30
millionen schaffen wir wollen aber dann
noch einmal 30 millionen menschen mit
einer booster impfung versehen sodass
wir optimalerweise sechzig millionen
oder bis zu 60 millionen
booster geimpfte zum schluss hätten und
dafür haben wir noch 30 millionen
moderner impfstoff zur verfügung und
noch ungefähr drei millionen dosen bei
und dämmstoff ja bei und dämmstoff ist
etwas knapper die sich bei der inventur
gezeigt hat die wir zu diesem thema
durchgeführt haben trotzdem ist der
moderne impfstoffe ein besonders guter
impfstoff und ich möchte diese
gelegenheit nochmal nutzen um auch an
die tiere lassen gelassenen kolleginnen
und kollegen aber auch die impfärzte zu
appellieren diesen impfstoff einzusetzen
neue daten zeigen dass die
autoantikörper konzentration nach der
booster dosis die viralen setzen die
50er dosis um den faktor
37 an stark dass ein massiver anstieg
den aus moderner hier auf was somit an
besonders gut geeignet musterimpfstoff
den ich hier so ausdrücklich empfehlen
für diese impfung für die unter 30
jährigen hat die stiko empfohlen den bau
und dämmstoffe einzusetzen diese
empfehlung wird derzeit von der stiko
noch einmal geprüft auch auf meinen
wünschen was da also herauskommt war
sich nicht an die stiko ist ein
unabhängiges gremium darauf nehmen wir
keinen einfluss aber zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt bitte ich die niedergelassenen
kolleginnen und kollegen den bayern keck
im stoff daher bei den unter 30-jährigen
einzusetzen so dass wir dort auch die
booster im punkt mit vollem tempo machen
können und den modernen stoff bei den
über 30-jährigen die wirksamkeit des
moderner impfstoffes ist mindestens so
gut wie dieses impfstoffes so dass wir
dann also ohne einschränkung mustern
kann ich freue mich bei dieser
gelegenheit auch also
kassen heute begrüßen zu können
in der diese initiativen unterstützt
aber gleich etwas dazu sagen wir werden
auch in den zeiten vom 24.12 bis zum 19
erster um eben auch das engagement der
ärzteschaft zu würdigen und noch einmal
das so aufzurufen das so viel gebucht
hat wird wie irgend möglich werden wir
in der gesamten zeit also vom 24.12 bis
zum neunten erster werden wir das sonn
und feiertags budget fahren das heißt es
gibt pro impfung dann 36 euro und nicht
die 28 euro weil ich weiß es zu schätzen
dass hier eröffnen und ärzte nun auch
die daran hängenden teams bereit sind in
den feiertagen zu impfen ich bitte darum
den zentren offen zu halten ich bitte
darum die praxen also als impfzentren zu
nutzen wir also haben hier aus meiner
sicht eine einmalige chance wenn es uns
gelingen würde 50 bis 60 millionen
menschen in deutschland mit einer
booster impfung zu also versehen dann
schützt das diese menschen von schwerer
krankheit es entschleunigt aber auch
dramatisch die das fortschreiten der
pandemie also omikron pandemie und
schützt somit zum schluss auch die
ungeimpften
natürlich also machen wir alles was wir
können um die ungeimpften zu erreichen
und wir werden für die umgehen die
umgehenden warten ja zum teil auch tod
dem stoffe werden wir in kurzer nowaks
impfstoff anbieten dafür haben wir vier
millionen dosen gekauft ich stehe wieder
zur verfügung so weit das werk liefern
kann aber ich will noch mal darauf
hinweisen wollen wir die ungeimpften mit
schützen und viele ungeimpfte sind keine
wer denke das sind keine menschen in dem
staat gegenüber kritisch stehen trotzdem
menschen die zum teil die impfung
aufgeschoben haben die fragen haben aber
wollen wir die umgebenden schützen dann
müssen wir tatsächlich die pandemie
entschleunigung und diese
entschleunigung ist nur möglich durch
eine möglichst schnelle poster kampagne
werden wir die 30 millionen dem stoff
verbraucht haben die wir jetzt nutzen
kommt mehr impfstoff ich habe noch
einmal 25 millionen
gesamt dosen besorgt von moderner das
sind insgesamt 50 millionen booster
impfung das heißt wir können wirklich so
schnell und zu viel boostern wie wir
wollen es kommt nur darauf an wie gut
wird das organisiert haben so viel von
meiner seite hier bezogen vw vielen dank
herr minister herr professor wille hat
das war ja mein und herren während der
feiertage und zum jahreswechsel wird die
epidemiologische lage nur unvollständig
abgebildet sein warum ist das so das
liegt daran dass viele menschen im
urlaub sind und in folge dessen sind zum
beispiel auch viele arztpraxen geschäfte
oder auch andere institutionen
geschlossen wir wissen dass in dieser
zeit meist weniger personen einen arzt
aufsuchen es gibt weniger testungen am
arbeitsplatz und natürlich auch in den
kitas und schulen denn diese sind ja
geschlossen dadurch werden weniger
proben genommen und dadurch werden auch
weniger labor untersuchungen
durchgeführt und das führt dazu dass
natürlich letztlich auch weniger erreger
nachweise an die gesundheitsämter
gemeldet werden aber wir wissen
natürlich trotzdem ganz genau was zu tun
ist welche maßnahmen umzusetzen sind am
wichtigsten ist neben dem impfen je
weniger menschen zusammenkommen je
kleiner das kontaktnetzwerk ist desto
weniger verbreitet sich das virus
unser aller verhalten ist hier wirklich
entscheidend in den vergangenen wochen
waren die fallzahlen rückläufig aber
leider ist das noch kein zeichen für
eine entspannung
kein incident von fast 300 ist immer
noch zu hoch und über 50 kreise haben
heute noch immer ins identen über 500
kliniken intensivstation sind weiterhin
am limit viele operationen werden nach
wie vor abgesagt es liegen immer noch
etwa viereinhalb 1000 kubik patienten
auf intensivstationen
auch das ist immer noch ein hohes niveau
und es werden weiterhin woche für woche
etwa 2000 todesfälle in verbindung mit
kurven 19 registriert auch longo witt
beeinträchtigt natürlich weiterhin sehr
sehr viele betroffene und deswegen
müssen wir die immer noch sehr hohen
fallzahlen weiter runter bekommen
auch weil wir damit rechnen müssen dass
die fallzahlen in absehbarer zeit wieder
steigen und vor allem durch micon muss
mit einer infektionswelle gerechnet
werden von einer bislang noch nicht
gesehenen dynamik in immer mehr ländern
verbreitet sich omikron sehr schnell
extrem schnell zum beispiel in
großbritannien oder unseren
nachbarländern dänemark und frankreich
in deutschland sind nach den neuesten
daten bislang und 540 fälle und
verdachtsfälle als robert koch institut
übermittelt worden dass der heutige
stand die daten sind überwiegend ein bis
zwei wochen altes wissen sie wir schauen
in den meldedaten ja immer zurück wenn
es melder verzugs und insbesondere auch
wegen des zeitbedarf für eine sequenz
analyse und über die feiertage ist wie
gesagt zu erwarten dass weniger proben
genommen und damit auch analysiert
werden können aber der trend ist
glasklar bei einer verdopplung zeit von
etwa drei tagen
könnte die neue variante in den nächsten
ein zwei spätestens drei wochen bereits
die mehrzahl aller infektionsfälle in
unserem land ausmachen wir können nach
wie vor nicht sicher einschätzen ob
oregon weniger krank macht aber selbst
wenn dies so wäre und mir kann es extrem
ansteckend und kann dem immunsystem
leichter entkommen das führt auch bei
genesenen und zweimal geimpften häufiger
zu infektionen und diese können eben
auch weitergegeben werden die nicht oder
nicht vollständig geimpften sind
weiterhin gefährdet daher ist zu
erwarten dass sich die situation in
kürze wieder verschärfen wird wenn es
nicht gelingt die dynamik der mikrowelle
mit strikten maßnahmen zu bremsen muss
aufgrund der in kurzer zeit zu
erwartenden hohen erkrankungszahlen mit
einer überlastung des gesundheitssystems
gerechnet werden und nicht nur das es
muss auch mit einer beeinträchtigung
kritischer versorgungsstrukturen
gerechnet werden denn wenn viele
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen zur
gleichen zeit erkranken oder als enge
kontaktpersonen in quarantäne müssen
dann fehlen sie natürlich bei der arbeit
die gute nachricht mit einer dritten
impfung verbessert sich der schutz vor
einer symptomatischen inflation auf etwa
70 bis 80 prozent und das ist wirklich
viel deswegen ist die
auffrischungsimpfung so wichtig aber
natürlich auch die noch fehlen erst und
zweitens weil nikon eine so hohe dynamik
bringt hat das lka am montag seine
risikobewertung zur vip 19 geändert für
die gruppe der ungeimpften wird die
infektions gefährdung als sehr hoch
eingeschätzt es gibt in deutschland auch
etwa elf millionen erwachsene die um 15
obwohl es ausreichend fundierte daten
zur wirksamkeit und zur sicherheit der
impfstoffe gibt für die chinesen und
geimpften mit zweimaliger impfung
schätzen wir die infektions gefährdung
als hoch ein und für die drei mal
geimpft als moderat auch die ständige
impfkommission hat rasch auf die
zunehmende verbreitung von omikron
reagiert und gestern ihre empfehlungen
zur auffrischungsimpfung angepasst die
stiko empfiehlt die auffrischung mit nun
mit einem verkürzten abstand von
mindestens drei monaten zur
grundimmunisierung dazu zufügen bei der
auffrischimpfung sollte man nicht auf
einen wunsch im stoff warten sondern das
nehmen was vorhanden ist beide
impfstoffe von biotech und moderner
führen mit der auffrischung zu einem
guten schutz vor der omicron variante
ja wir alle möchten die feiertage und
mit der familie und mit freunden und
verwandten verbringen das weihnachtsfest
soll aber nicht der funke sein der das
omikron feuer entfacht im gegenteil wir
alle müssen dafür sorgen diese zeit
zwischen jahr zu nutzen um die dynamik
aus dem infektionsgeschehen
herauszunehmen ich bitte sie deshalb
eindringlich verbringen sie diese zeit
wirklich nur im kleineren kreis von
freunden verwandten und familie bitte
schränken sie ihre kontakte auf das
nötigste ein treffen sie möglichst
wenige und wenn dann immer dieselben
menschen in einem festen sozialen kreis
am sichersten ist es natürlich wenn alle
vollständig zweimal geimpft sind und
eine auffrischungsimpfung hatten wenn
sie sich mit menschen aus risikogruppen
treffen zum beispiel alten hoch alten
chronisch kranken dann sollten sie sich
vorher wirkte immer unbedingt testen
auch wenn sie vollständig geimpft sind
und verzichten sie auf reisen die nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind lassen sie uns
gemeinsam dafür sorge tragen dass die
bevorstehende mikrowelle möglichst flach
verläuft
vielen dank ja sehr damen und herren sie
haben es gilt minister laut aber hat
skizziert wie wir trotz der anstehenden
und zu befürchtenden nikon welle von der
wir alle noch nicht wissen was sie für
uns wirklich in der realität dann
bedeuten wird wie wir trotzdem
da das ganze
mit impfung in den griff bekommen und
jetzt stellt sich natürlich für viele
von ihnen die frage ist das realistisch
dieses ich ziehe und dann kann ich die
an der stelle beruhigen das ist
realistisch und wir haben tatsächlich
auch in der vergangenheit in einem
selbst für mich fast überraschenden
tempo diese booster impfungen
hinbekommen es war sie haben das gehört
immer die zahl 30 millionen
auffrischimpfung bis ende des jahres
ausgerufen worden und da haben wir schon
alle greifen wenn wir das schaffen wäre
ich kann ihnen sagen stand gestern sind
wir bei knapp 28 millionen 100.000 also
sogar noch etwas höher als die zahl der
minister gerade von kommuniziert die
habe ich vor 10 minuten bekommen die
niedergelassenen ärzte mit den teams
haben wirklich hier
großes geleistet das muss man so sagen
wir haben so viele impfungen pro woche
wie noch nie zuvor in deutschland
wir impfen über sechs millionen menschen
jede woche und sie können vielleicht aus
weil ich dann auch die 30 millionen die
dann noch anstehen für die verbleibenden
folgerung ist letztlich in einem guten
monat bis ende januar zu schaffen damit
ist deutschland weit über dem eu schnitt
auch das muss glaube ich mal deutlich
gemacht werden wir holen das vereinigte
königreich ein das deutlich früher
angefangen hat zwei dieser drei
impfungen werden den praxen gemacht in
der letzten woche waren es rund fünf
millionen impfungen praxen davon 4,2
millionen booster impfung was zeigt auch
die ersten zwei impfungen gegen gott sei
dank wieder zu insgesamt beteiligen sich
aktuell knapp 84.000 kolleginnen und
kollegen an den impfungen ziemlich genau
hälfte haus erste hälfte fachärzte und
die entstehen natürlich diese hohen
impfzahlen nicht nur durch den
zunehmenden zahl von kolleginnen und
kollegen sondern auch durch mehr impfung
pro impfstelle das ist gut im 7 tages
schnitt sind das 27.000 tägliche
impfungen ich möchte hier an der stelle
noch mal ganz herzlich bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen in den praxen
bedanken das ist eine enorme
zusatzbelastung auch für die teams und
das ist nicht selbstverständlich findet
trotzdem
mal eine erwähnung wert dass das hier
neben der normalen versorgung geleistet
wird also das ziel 30 millionen in form
bis jahresende ist erreichbar da glaube
ich brauchen wir keine zweifel mehr
daran heben und ich glaube auch dass wir
den rest der zur brust und bevölkerung
bei ausreichend impfstoff kapazitäten
das scheint der fall zu sein dann auch
im januar
entsprechend boostern können der
minister hat schon die größenordnungen
genannt die zur verfügung stehen auch
mal auf die wertigkeit auch gerade der
booster durch moderne hingewiesen die
aktuellen zahlen sind sehr ermutigend
damit hat man tatsächlich wieder ein
sehr wirkungsvollen schutz erstimpfung
auch da gibt es positives zu berichten
nicht in dem umfang wie wir ihn uns
wünschen würden aber immerhin werden
jede woche jetzt eine über eine halbe
million erstimpfung erreicht auch das
ist ein positives signal da sind 20
prozent der kinder impfung aber
nichtsdestotrotz scheint es auch
zunehmend doch erwachsen zu geben die
den wert der impfung für sich anerkennen
und wir können an der stelle nur noch
mal dazu aufrufen das ist das schärfste
schwert im kampf gegen korona ist die
impfung vollständig geimpft und nach
einer gewissen zeit die booster rung
nowaks wurde schon erwähnt steht an
genau in welcher menge nowaks zur
verfügung steht wissen wir noch nicht
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wir hier
den ein oder anderen noch erreichen der
bisher mit den mma impfstoffen haderte
die botschaft ist also aus meiner sicht
wir haben eine eine gute chance mit der
booster kampagne in dem hohen tempo und
wie sagt man mit der vernunft der
menschen die sich völlig unvernünftig
habe die letzten wochen gezeigt die
zahlen sinken die menschen passen mit
mehr auf sich und andere auf glaube ich
kriegen wir das hin haben eine gute
chance hier nicht vor eine
unüberbrückbare
infektions und krankenstands wand zu
laufen und ich glaube das ist
zunächst mal eine gute botschaft ist
kamen auch die
angesprochen kritische infrastruktur wie
gefährlich ist es wenn uns plötzlich in
großer zahl natürlich auch
kolleginnen kollegen und mitarbeiter in
den praxen oder kliniken wegbrechen da
wir rund 100000 praxen haben sind die
natürlich nicht für infektionen gefeiert
aber sind das system an sich ist etwas
reservierter weil wir dann einzelne
kleine einheiten haben die mal ausfallen
können dass die in der gesamtheit
flächendeckend ausfallen ist
unwahrscheinlich insofern sind wir auch
hier hoffnungsfroh dass wir die
impfkampagne ohne wesentliche gibt's
auch über die weihnachtstage fortführen
könne nicht hinter ist ein sehr gutes
signal den kollegen bringen hier auch
eine entsprechende wirtschaftliche
anerkennung zukommen zu lassen weil es
natürlich auch zwischen den tagen die
zusätze herausfallen ist auch mit
personal bei ja viele medizinische
fachangestellte auch kinder haben geht
das zu die müssen die auch versorgung
trotzdem glaube ich wir kriegen das
gemeinsam gut hin die resonanz aus den
kollegen ist er wohl ich hab heute
morgen noch mit den kv chefs der länder
gesprochen und auch hier gibt es eine
breite zustimmung zur info und booster
kampagne man wünscht natürlich noch ein
bisschen abbau der bürokratie da können
wir sicherlich bei der gelegenheit noch
drüber sprechen aber insgesamt glaube
ich sind wir gut aufgestellt und können
durchaus mit einer gewissen
selbstbewusstsein und hoffnung in die
zukunft schauen
der hand jetzt zeit für fragen bis halb
zwei dann müssen wir lüften für die
nächste pressekonferenz damit dass hier
auch alles ordnungsgemäß abläuft
ich habe bereits jetzt ungefähr 20
fragen vorliegen von kolleginnen und
kollegen die sich gemeldet haben ich
versuche hier einen einigermaßen guten
ausgleich zu schaffen zwischen innen und
online zugespielten fragen die erste hat
es hier im saal mit vielen dank im
grunde sind es 3 3 kurz an jeden
einzelnen herr gassen ist moderner
genauso einfach zufall impfen in den
praxen biontech im umgang damit herr
lauterbach boostern wichtig was machen
sie oder was sagen sie zu den kindern
die sich jetzt zweimal geimpft haben
müssen die auch gewusst hat werde ich
vor allen dingen auch die idee im schon
im juni oder juli auch ledige empfohlen
sind die müssten können jetzt auch weil
sie sagen drei monate und das problem
ist moderner ist glaube ich für gut 30
regel nicht die richtige aber das können
sie sicherlich besser beantworten und
herr wieland muss eigentlich ist früher
seien mit den kontakt beschränkungen das
was wir gesagt haben als der 28 dezember
um die mikrowelle zu brechen auch weil
ja nicht getestet wird zum teil und die
praxen zu sind vielen dank ich hätte
noch vergessen zu sagen dass wir immer
so wie sonst auch immer eine frage eine
nachfrage stellen das wäre so nett vom
zeitbudget was wir haben hier die
anderen kollegen schon natürlich ist
also ganz kurz der anwender muss er
grundsätzlich ist moderne natürlich in
der praxis genauso als wenn das problem
das haben sie damit impliziert gefragt
ist dadurch dass die weit größer sind
wir bei dem booster in 24 dosen aus
einem weil bekommen was an sich gut ist
ist es organisatorisch etwas aufwendiger
und deshalb vielleicht an der stelle der
appell die menschen sollten wirklich
versuchen sie in den praxen termine
geben zuerst erwartet die organisation
erheblich es ist dann relativ
unproblematisches der wirtschaft
hochwirksam keine frage aber die
packungsgröße erfordert eine gewisse vor
laufende planung deshalb bitte nicht
einfach in die praxen kommen sondern
vielleicht kurz vor
vielen dank die booster impfung für
kinder ist nicht zugelassen zum
günstigen zeitpunkt wenn sie aber
vorgenommen
weil es sich ja um zugelassene impfstoff
behandelt übernimmt der bund die haftung
ja zu den kontakt einschränkungen also
die der gestrige mpk beschluss war er
sehr eindeutig das steht ja immer dass
spätestens zum 28
diese kontakt mal kontakt einschränkung
maßnahmen vorgenommen werden sollen
insofern ist der zeitraum wann das in
den einzelnen bundesländern wirklich
gemacht wird ja sowieso offen aber ich
denke was sehr wichtig ist und was ja
auch der expertenrat am wochenende klar
gemacht hat und was auch in dem mpk
beschluss steht natürlich wird
unabhängig davon ja an jeden einzelnen
appelliert dass er oder sie schon die
kontakte so gut wie möglich einschränkt
und das ist ja das entscheidende das
haben wir glaube ich in dieser pandemie
die ganze zeit immer gelernt sind
wahnsinnig davon ab wie sich die
menschen unserem land verhalten in
rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten und wir sehen
in den letzten wochen monaten dass dort
sehr viel verständnis ist und dass das
von der mehrheit der menschen getragen
wird und das ist das warum wir ja auch
zahlen sehen die runtergehen in den
meisten bundesländern insofern ist ja
schon adäquat
aber das qoc rtl eine frage an den
gesundheitsminister lauterbacher leute
rannten die maske auf lassen wenn sie
fragen das hat sich hier ganz gut
bewährt danke herr lauterbach
wenn es so wichtig ist dass die zweite
booster werde so weiterläuft wie die
erste zu sein werden verspricht wie
steht es denn damit der ausreichende
versorgung mit impfstoff also
über wie sieht es aus mit bayern-chef
weil 30 hat er doch eben auf diesen
impfstoff angewiesen ist in die ferne
könnte da ein mangel eventuell eben den
den fortgang isabelle hemmen vielen dank
für die fall die antwort ist ganz
einfach wir haben 30 millionen dosen
booster dosen von moderner jetzt zur
verfügung für die nächsten drei wochen
zehn millionen pro woche und haben
insgesamt also über diese zeit 3
millionen bei und deckt zur verfügung
pro woche also erste woche 1,2 millionen
die woche darauf 0,8 die nächste woche
darauf 12 mehr ist es nicht ich hatte
ich ein anderer gelegenheit darauf
hingewiesen was sie im rahmen einer
inventur also festgestellt hatten dass
nicht so viel bei und tag im stoff also
beschafft worden war wir arbeiten
allerdings fieberhaft also jetzt daran
noch weiteren dienst noch zu besorgen
ich kann auf jeden fall ankündigen dass
wir also 25 millionen dosen moderner
impfstoff noch beschaffen konnten in
anschluss an die 30 millionen die wsh
diese 25 millionen sind doppelt losen
das wäre dann so viel dass man damit 50
millionen booster impfungen machen
könnte und es wird gleichzeitig auch
versucht also bei dem stoff zusätzlichen
biotec im stoff zu besorgen
da sind wir mit mehreren ländern also
für den direktkauf bilateralen kauf im
gespräch darüber kann ich aber erst
vortragen wenn diese gespräche
erfolgreich sind
ich habe eine frage von anno fricke von
der erste zeitung an sie herr minister
lauterbach da geht es um datenschutz und
statistik wie können die daten der
bereits geimpften unter einhaltung aller
datenschutzbestimmungen bei den
niedergelassenen ärzten und den
impfzentren abgerufen werden daran
arbeiten wir derzeit
es gibt ja zum beispiel auch die frage
für deutschland ein im krieg ist ein ja
oder nein das prüfen wir wir prüfen
sowie die daten derjenigen die brass
geimpft worden sind also in ein solches
register werden dass es gebe ein
gepflegt werden könnten das sind große
aufgaben an denen wir derzeit also
arbeiten aber auf der anderen seite ist
so es so also zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
muss es erstmal darum geben gehen mit
möglichst großem tempo
unbürokratisch viel zu impfen es geht um
den schutz der bevölkerung das heißt es
ist jetzt im moment nicht
ist nicht die gelegenheit wo ich eine
weitere bürokratische hürde bereit wäre
einzuführen zur dokumentation sondern
jetzt muss wirklich im bestehenden
rahmen so schnell wie möglich geimpft
werden herr kollege sebastian heinrich
vom nach hinter watson herr lauterbach
ja wieder was gerade für die jungen
menschen nicht verstehen warum dürfen
auch nach den jüngsten im pk beschlüssen
cafés und bars weiterhin geöffnet sein
clubs aber nicht also in beiden arten
von lokalen wird alkohol konsumiert in
beiden sind die menschen bisweilen eng
beieinander und marcus schulz hat von
der kosmetischen unterscheidung da
gesprochen die da getroffen wird die
keinen unterschied macht können sie das
erklären diesen unterschied
also ich kann das wird dazu etwas sagen
es kommt immer darauf an also was jetzt
im vordergrund des betriebs steht auch
das also große tanz gelegen hatten sind
wir dann zum teil
150 200 menschen zusammengekommen sind
oder in innenräumen daneben 50 und das
haben wir jetzt halt sehr stark
eingeschränkt die gastronomie
der verzehr im vordergrund steht hat
also von denen also
pandemischen
herausforderungen nicht genau diese
bedeutung aber selbstverständlich ist
das was man im blick haben muss wir
werden ja das was wir tun weiter
auswerten das was wir jetzt gemacht
haben geht im wesentlichen auf
empfehlungen und auch gespräch mit dem
expertenrat zurück und darauf an was
bezogen
das ist vielleicht noch
bietet jede von der blüte
hat gestern mit der veröffentlichung
eines extra papiers für erheblichen
wirbel erheblichen wirbel gesorgt auch
in der mpk es gab da relativ heftige
äußerung vom bundeskanzler und auch von
ihnen herr lauterbach daher die frage
stehen sie zu herrn wieder ist er fest
im sattel und an händler die frage warum
haben sie gestern also so kurz nachdem
experten raten sie selber angehören ein
weitergehendes papier veröffentlicht
unterlassen was haben sie gedacht als
sie das gelesen habe
nicht angekommen mit der einen frage ich
dann schick ich jetzt mal noch eine
hinterher weil ich hier die leitung und
zwar fragte timm cent ivanyi von rnd sie
herr lauterbach wie verärgert sind sie
über lka-präsident vieler wegen der
forderungen nach umgehender bestückung
das thematisch daran hast ja vielen dank
hier kamen jetzt mal die frage ob ich zu
einem wlan noch stehe
das lässt sich leicht beantworten sonst
serien nicht
und
und die zweite frage also verärgert das
sind interna
es ist so also in meinem haus gibt es
keine zensur was wissenschaftliche
arbeiten angeht müssen wir es doch nicht
geben daher bin ich also dankbar wenn
also
wenn wissenschaftliche auswertungen mich
erreichen hier war es so dass sie mich
nicht mehr erreicht hatten vor der
eigentlichen sitzung da wird die
abstimmung noch optimiert werden aber
ich will ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen
hab mir mal gesagt also dass also ein
kern baustein meiner arbeit darin liegen
wird dass ich mich sehr stark auch am
jeweiligen wissenschaftlichen
sachverstand orientiere und da ist auch
das robert koch institut eine ganz
zentrale quelle
ich habe dem nichts hinzuzufügen
sie müssten schon ins mikrofon sprechen
das hätte vorteile ver.di wollte
verdiener wieder nicht wissen ob er
lauter machen braucht noch zu ihnen
steht sondern warum dieses geld getan
haben und das würde ich doch ganz gerne
antwort das robert koch institut gibt ja
kontinuierlich empfehlungen heraus das
ist ja unsere aufgabe das hat sich
natürlich in den letzten zwei jahren
auch nicht geändert
ich habe eine frage von der kollegin
lisa braun von der presseagentur
gesundheit die fragt auch nach den
jungen bund länder beschlossen
stichwort wissenschaftliche evidenz
corona kennt keine ländergrenzen und
kann weihnacht welche politische rolle
hat das weihnachtsfest bei den jüngsten
bund länder beschlossen gespielt vielen
dank für diese wichtige frage
wir sind zunächst einmal davon
ausgegangen auf der grundlage von
auswertungen der vergangen waren das
tage dass also die weihnachtstage keine
besondere also epidemisch
herausforderungen da ich denn die fans
in den letzten jahren nicht wesentlich
gestiegen trotzdem ist das für mich noch
einmal eine gelegenheit
anzuknüpfen an das was herr gassen auch
schon dankenswerterweise gesagt hatte
wir müssen hier in den weihnachtstagen
besonders aufeinander achtgeben und ich
rate daher allen die ihre verwandten
besuchen die gemeinsam nach hause kommen
ich rate allen sich vorher zu testen
also nicht nur denjenigen die ältere
besuchen die auch ungeimpfte besuchen
sondern die testung vor der abreise
bevorzugt mehrere tests hintereinander
also ein zweites hintereinander das gibt
die mit großem abstand größte sicherheit
weil man sich dann auch nicht auf der
fahrt zur zu den verwandten infiziert
und kleine gruppen sind besser als große
gruppen gerade bei älteren menschen ist
großer wert darauf zu legen dass man
fragt sind die älteren menschen schon
gepostet jahren waren war die booster
impfung
daher also
mit kleinen gruppen sich treffen und
wenn immer möglich das wäre der zentrale
baustein antigen testung an mehreren
denn hintereinander
fabian busch von web.de und gmx.de
lauter noch im koalitionsvertrag steht
dass das lka künftig wissenschaftlich
weisungsgebunden arbeiten soll bleibt
das weiterhin das ziel denn wenn das
papier gestern vom lka so viele aufruhr
erregt hat dann zeigt das ja dass die
politik da vielleicht gar nicht für
bereit ist
ich glaube ich habe die frage schon
beantwortet
wissenschaftlicher sachverstand vom
expertenrat vom rk ii auch von
unabhängigen experten mit denen ich
regelmäßigen austausch bin übrigens auch
in england selbst ich werde heute
nachmittag mit dem englischen
gesundheitsminister und noch mit
englischen wissenschaftlern mich noch
einmal über die anlage ebendort
auseinandersetzen das ist also etwas was
meine arbeit prägen wird und da ist auch
was er kann ganz zentraler baustein
herren hochsteiner rufe ich von mir aus
zu dass mir ihre fragen beantwortet
scheint bitte melden sie sich noch mal
falls sie das anders sehen die nächste
frage von bernhard junginger von der
augsburger allgemeinen zeitung und geht
zum thema kritische infrastruktur zu
welchem zeitpunkt ist nach den
erkenntnissen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums eine
gefahr für die kritische infrastruktur
durch omikron infektionen beim personal
zu befürchten
das können wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht sagen wir modellieren also
die entwicklung
und sind auf jeden fall in intensiver
vorberatung also was alle bereiche der
kritischen infrastruktur angeht das sind
also nicht nur die medizinischen
bereiche sondern das geht über polizei
feuerwehr strom wasser also auch
lebensmittelversorgung alles wird
derzeit im prinzip monitor irrt und
vorbereitet aber ob und wann uns andere
welt treffen würde dass diese notfall
pläne umgesetzt werden müssen das wissen
wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht wir
hoffen dass noch abwenden zu können im
wesentlichen auch durch die
gepflegten kontakt beschränkungen die
poster kampagne
da gibt es den gästen weiter hier im
saal
saßen freier journalist herr villa der
die bonländer runde gestern hat sich
ihrer beschlussfassung explizit an dem
beschluss des expertenrates dem sie
angehören orientiert was hat sie
veranlasst und die frage ist noch nicht
beantwortet
was hat sie veranlasst
wissend worauf die bund länder sich
geeinigt haben dann doch zeitnah eine
davon abweichende
positionen zu formulieren
also ob wie gesagt dazu hatte mich auch
schon geäußert der expertenrat wenn sie
das papier wirklich gründlich lesen dann
stellen sie auch fest dass dort keine
konkreten empfehlungen gemacht werden
sondern dort steht ja eine analyse der
lage und die aufforderung dass etwas
getan werden muss und das wird ja auch
getan und das ist eben eine institution
die das in konkrete empfehlungen dann
ummünzt das ist ja in dem expertenbeirat
nicht getan worden insofern ist es ja
keinerlei widerspruch es ist eigentlich
aber auch keine antwort denn
die bund länder runde hat sich gestern
sozusagen eine interpretation der
empfehlung zu eigen gemacht beschlüsse
oder zeit ihr mix daraus abgeleitet das
wussten sie sie haben eine empfehlung
mit anderen schafen daten veröffentlicht
noch mal die frage was hat sie zu der
schärferen variante veranlasst darin
steckt doch die kritik dass das was bund
länder beschließen oder vorschlagen
nicht ausreichend ist
also ich hab das so in erinnerung dass
unsere empfehlung vor dem beschluss der
mpk auf der website
wir wussten aber doch mit verlaub was
die ministerpräsidenten und der kanzler
sagen würden das ist ja innerhalb von
zwei tagen wie die runde selbst gesagt
hat zusammengestellt worden sie wussten
dass und in kenntnis dieses
vorher gemacht so was war jetzt die
frage die frage die frage war
warum kommen sie tschuldigung mit einem
formalen argument wenn sie sagen wir
haben es dabei wir
veröffentlicht sie wussten wie die bund
länder runde sich positionieren wurde er
noch haben sie eine scharfe
empfehlung ausgesprochen warum ich kann
nicht in die zukunft schauen ich weiß
nicht was beschlossen wird in der
zukunft
keine sorgen vielen dank
es wurde ja schon also darauf
hingewiesen wir müssen nach vorne
blicken wir müssen nach vorne blicken
wie schaffen wir das jetzt und wir haben
hier klare beschlüsse gestern gefasst
das ist ein schlüssel die werden den
abfall der fälle weiter beschleunigen
wir werden einen weiteren rückgang der
fälle sehen und dann werden in dieser
zeit die poster kampagne fahren somit
also versuchen wir eine besonders
schwere mikrowelle noch abzuwenden man
muss nach vorne blicken und ich
persönlich finde die diskussion also war
das jetzt also ungünstig so platziert
oder nicht also das finde ich nicht so
besonders interessant sondern ist auch
gemeinsam jetzt schauen wie kriegen wir
das bewältigt und da bin ich
zuversichtlich
das ziel ist die identisch man das muss
man auch mal sagen also alle die
entscheidenden unserem land haben wir
dasselbe ziel nämlich wir wollen die
fälle senken und das gelingt ja auch
seit einigen wochen
ich habe jetzt frage fragen zur test
kapazitäten da würde ich gerne zwei
zusammenfassen die in dieselbe richtung
gehen jungen klecken klöckner vom
handelsblatt fragt sie herr lauterbach
und herrn wieder welche erkenntnisse
haben sie über die test kapazitäten
unternehmen befürchten oder vermelden
bereits engpässe und dazu hatte ich noch
eine weitere frage gesehen von sebastian
huld von n tv
bezogen auf ihre empfehlung dass die
bürger sich testen sollen der
einzelhandel bietet aber kaum selbst
test an schreibt der kollege holt wird
der bund sich dieser versorgung dieses
versorgungsmangel jetzt annehmen
ja
in der tat wir haben in einzelnen
regionen jetzt so die belastungsgrenze
bei der pcr testung erreicht das ist so
aber es ist keine überforderung das
heißt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gibt es
keine region wo die pcr test nicht mehr
durchgeführt werden kann soll es kann
allenfalls zu einer leichten verzögerung
der mitteilung der ergebnisse kommen was
die anti gen tests angeht sind wir also
nicht im system der zentralen
beschaffung sondern das regelt der markt
zählt aber mit dem unternehmen in
kontakt und uns wird mitgeteilt dass der
bedarf gedeckt werden könne
ich gehe hier nur zur information der
kolleginnen und kollegen die es sehr
eilig haben der reihenfolge nach vorbei
wir uns hier in teufels küche
herfried ist der nächste
also pardon ich hatte das auch schon
einzelne ortet minister und ein fehler
ich hätte eine frage noch mal zu der
expertenrat geschichte sowie das
vorgestern und gestern gelaufen ist
entsteht der eindruck dass im
expertenrat zwar ein einstimmiges
ergebnis herrscht das dann aber nur ein
kompromiss ist eine art kleinste
gemeinsame nenner und einzelne
mitglieder des expertenrats sowie er
wieder oder das rkw als ganzes dann
weitergehende vorschläge haben ist das
eigentlich sinnvoll wenn der expertenrat
sich nicht mit 19 stimmen von 19 auf das
bestmögliche einigt sondern nur auf das
was man sich halt als kompromiss
reinigen kann
ja vielen dank es ist nicht so dass ich
mich auch mit den mitgliedern des
expertenrats im austausch und wohne den
also sitzungen typischerweise auch bei
und das abzuqualifizieren als den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner ist nicht
durch die experten etwa sehr klaren ja
so gravierend die welle sein wird die
wir hier erwarten müssen ist auch sehr
klar darüber gewesen wie gefährlich auch
mikron ist ist auch sehr klar darüber
gewesen dass wir hier sogar ein schutz
der kritischen infrastruktur also
vornehmen müssen ist auch sehr klar
darüber gewesen dass wir jetzt nicht
ausschließen können dass die omi konnte
ähnlich schwer verläuft also wie die
täter variante das sind alles sehr klare
aussagen und auch keine aussagen die
aufgrund sofort oder zur entwarnung
machen und daher ist meine einschätzung
die dass sie hier einen graben oft runde
in wirklichkeit nicht besteht und die
ergebnisse im expertenrat sind also
alarmierend gewesen und das haben wir
auch umgesetzt und durchsichtig
ich würde das gern noch mal gern zu dass
einfach wirklich ganz sachlich und
nüchtern darzustellen mir liegt dieses
papier des expertenrates vor da steht in
das ist der letzte absatz das ist eine
schlussfolgerung zeitnah notwendige
maßnahmen aus dem geschilderten szenario
ergibt sich handlungsbedarf bereits für
die kommenden tage wirksame bundesweit
abgestimmte gegenmaßnahmen zur kontrolle
desinfektions geschehens sind
vorzubereiten insbesondere gut geplante
und gut kommunizierte kontakt
beschränkungen dann steht da die aktuell
geltenden maßnahmen müssen darüber
hinaus noch stringenter fortgeführt
werden ich wüsste nicht wo das
irgendeine interpretationsspielraum
offen lässt aber der expertenrat hat
eben keine konkreten maßnahmen
beschlossen ist kein kompromiss papier
sondern ist eine sehr nüchterne analyse
die fordert dass stringentere maßnahmen
fortgeführt werden müssen
dann gehe ich weiter mit einer frage von
charlotte kurz von der pharmazeutischen
zeitung die nach nowaks fragt sie herr
minister lauterbach wann werden die
ersten nowaks impfstoffe nach
deutschland geliefert und verhilft
vielen dank wir haben vier millionen
impfdosen bestellt sind mit dem
unternehmen
kontakt und rechnen mit einer lieferung
im januar
dann geht es hier vorne weiter im soll
nochmal jörg ratzsch von dpa direkt an
herrn wieder nachfragen zu gestern abend
wie zufrieden oder unzufrieden sind sie
denn mit den ergebnissen der bund länder
beratung also ist sind stringentere
maßnahmen sie werden das
infektionsgeschehen deutlich vor langsam
und das ist sehr sehr gut und ansonsten
möchte ich das noch mal wiederholen wir
machen seit jahren empfehlungen immer
wieder empfehlungen und die werden wir
auch weitermachen und die umsetzung
dieser empfehlungen ist aufgabe der
politik ob ich zufrieden oder
unzufrieden ist ist völlig irrelevant
dann habe ich eine frage von patrick
hollstein von apotheke adhoc an sieben
minister lauterbach welche pläne und
erwartungen haben sie an praxen und
apotheken als teil der kritischen
infrastruktur um im fall von der rasant
steigenden infektionszahlen die
versorgung zu sichern
ja zunächst hoffen wir natürlich diese
rasant steigende infektionszahlen
abzuwenden aber
selbstverständlich sind praxen und auch
apotheken und auch krankenhäuser
zentraler baustein der kritischen
infrastruktur und wir haben hier in
früheren wählen also schon eine gewisse
erfahrung damit gehabt was ist also was
es bedeuten kann ich hoffe dass wir hier
also diesmal
besser gerüstet sind wegen der sehr
hohen impfquoten die wir in diesen
bereichen erreicht haben und die booster
impfung gerade in diesen bereichen ist
von größter bedeutung und daher hoffe
ich dass wir hier also die infrastruktur
geschützt haben selbstverständlich
werden pläne gemacht was passiert wenn
zb bestimmte krankenhäuser nicht voll
betrieben werden können
was machen wir zum beispiel mit reha
kliniken können rehakliniken dann auch
für also im bereich der akutversorgung
herangezogen werden das wird alles
geprüft und vorbereitet aber ich glaube
dass wir jetzt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
einfach noch hoffen können dass uns dies
spart platz vielleicht wäre gassen dazu
etwas sagen ja sie ist im grundsatz
schon ein richtiger wir haben hier zum
einen das muss man glaube ich noch mal
raus stellen gerade in praxen und auch
in den kliniken sehr hohe eben auch
booster quoten das ist eigentlich der
wirksamste schutz also ich gehe aus der
eigenen struktur da sind alle geben
schon gewusst hat und bei den praxen
kommt noch dazu dass hier ähnlich wie
die apotheke natürlich dezentral sind
also wenn dann einer ausfällt heißt das
ja nicht dass die ganze struktur
gefährdet ist und ansonsten müssen wir
da
reagieren werde ich die situation dass
wir die arena hat unterschiedlich sein
da braucht man nicht viel phantasie zwar
dass das möglicherweise in sachsen
thüringen er auftreten kann also in
schleswig holstein da muss man sich da
dinge zu überlegen eine möglichkeit sind
vernetzung das geschieht bei den praxen
auch häufig informell schon also ich bin
relativ zuversichtlich dass wir nicht
erleben werden dass die menschen nicht
mehr versorgt wären können trotzdem
müssen wir achtsamer sein und uns auch
mit solchen eventualitäten befassen aber
grundsätzlich halte ich die struktur die
der gast und praxen und in der folge
dann auch die der apotheke für recht
resilient
nicht noch mal eine nachricht an
bernhard walter von der badischen
zeitung die frage scheint mir auch
beantwortet zu sein die rwe eingespielt
hat sonst bitte nochmal melden und herr
hoffmann hat das wort
vom strahlen eine frage zum thema nowak
sie haben gesagt im januar werden die
fünf millionen dosen geliefert haben sie
sich eigentlich eine spezielle
verteilung überlegt der nowaks gilt
gerade bei ihm skeptikern er als
mögliche lösung das heißt wird er im
osten geliefert oder wie sieht das auto
der verteilung von oberbank
vielen dank eine spezielle verteilung
haben das nicht überlegt sondern
system von angebot und nachfrage werden
wir den impfstoff im
januar bekommen dann glaube ich wird er
von dort
angefragt haben wo diejenigen die diesen
stoff also bevorzugen nachfragen das
heißt ich rechne dann tatsächlich mit
also einer größeren nachfrage
in einigen bundesländern beispielsweise
sachsen sachsen anhalt
möglicherweise auch in teilen von bayern
das würde mich nicht überraschen was wir
nicht machen werden wir also
kontingentieren den impfstoff nicht und
wir werden noch mehr von dem impfstoff
also beschaffen worden und wir haben
auch von dem echten tod impfstoff
wallnöfer elf millionen dosen bestellt
dennoch nicht so gelassen ist
dann habe ich eine frage von markus
wacket von reuters an sie herr
lauterbach wie deutschland das pfizer
medikament
marxloh wied und das merkt präparat
cera wir sie sehen ich bin damit nicht
so vertraut kaufen um sich
beziehungsweise bei der eu dafür
einsetzen vielen dank mein opa wir haben
wir gekauft das heißt hier haben wir
eine bestellung verbindliche bestellung
getätigt und
praxis noch nicht zugelassen da sind wir
aber auch mit dem unternehmen bereits
also in
gesprächen und werden uns dann ebenfalls
eine entsprechende
ausstattung zu liegen dazu legen das
geht uns für alle medikamente die
zuverlässig also hier den schweren
verlauf verhindern können wir werden
dort alle möglichkeiten nutzen
jetzt geht es weiter mit der kollegin
kristin becker vermeide ich habe
herr lauterbach her wieder sie haben ja
betont wie wichtig das testen jetzt vor
weihnachten noch mal ist und dass das
zentral ist ich habe deswegen jetzt die
letzten tage noch mal geschaut wie
bisher mit den schneiders aussieht und
zumindest mal in berlin gibt es viele
schnelltest aufzukaufen und die
testzentren was mir dabei aber noch mal
aufgefallen ist es gibt ja diese tolle
liste von palma schon kann was die
qualität der tests ausmacht und in
großen supermärkten in großen
drogeriemarktketten sind die schnell
fest zum teil auf jeden fall
unterirdisch also quasi nicht zu nutzen
und sie werden massenhaft verkauft der
eine punkt wird auch im testzentrum
zumindest im privaten habe ich sozusagen
überprüft und da sind auch testen um auf
die unterirdisch schlecht sind ich frage
mich haben vorhin gesagt der markt
regelt das mit den schnelltest und es
sind im prinzip genug da das ist schön
dass welche da sind aber wenn die gar
nichts bringen dann ist das doch
ausgeschlossen dass geld und bei den
tests zentren noch dazu geld das wir als
allgemeinheit für tests die nichts
bringen wurden leute in falscher
sicherheit erhalten sie mal sogar in
frage kommt deswegen die frage was was
werden sie da tun oder was haben sie da
vielleicht auch schon angedacht dagegen
vorzugehen so kann es ja nicht
weitergehen
ja zunächst einmal dass bei also testet
ja die tests und stellt die ergebnisse
also ins netz so dass jeder sich selbst
informieren kann mein eindruck ist der
also dass die tests die besonders also
hochwertig sind den markt dominieren
also ich habe nicht den eindruck dass es
also anders ist ich schaue mir das aber
noch mal sehr gerne an dass sie sagen ja
jetzt also dass die testphase jetzt viel
verkauft werden minderwertig wären da
habe ich andere informationen ich kaufe
das aber selbst noch mal geht sehr gern
auch das bringt mich auf eine andere
frage die also hier wichtig ist und
naheliegend ist wirken die tests
eigentlich auch bei der omicron variante
und das ist so
davon ist auszugehen die test also
fassen also einen teil des also
der oberfläche der viren ab die
also unverändert sind der oberfläche ist
unverändert im vergleich data warnt
omikron variante und da die omikron
variante was sich also egal dem
nasen-rachen-raum explosionsartig also
verbreitet somit eine hohe viruslast
dort zu erwarten ist gehen wir davon aus
dass die also test bei der omicron
variante sehr zuverlässig funktionieren
dass auch die derzeitige studienlage
aber ich gehe ihre anregung noch einmal
nach ob tatsächlich also sehr weit
verbreitet es im angebot sind die auf
der grundlage der bewertung des preis
nicht nicht nicht hochwertig sind aber
noch mal nachfragen konnte sich das
andere micro entschuldigung ich hab es
falsch zugeordnet frage dazu wäre es
denn möglich von seiten des
gesundheitsministeriums da sie zumindest
die tests sind die privaten und auch die
öffentlichen aber auch die privaten
verpflichten hochwertige test von ihnen
geht das zumindest bei den supermärkten
zwar schwieriger das geht nicht weil die
tests ändern werden zugelassen mit allem
was dazugehört durch die euro länder und
die kommunen wir sind nicht die
betreiber der test sein sollen wir
können dort aber also
empfehlungen geben und ich greife ihre
anregung auf und noch einmal zu prüfen
ob wir da ein defizit haben
ich gucke ein bisschen auf die uhr und
habe jedoch noch einige fragen an den
küsten noch mal das signal das scheint
mir auch beantwortet jetzt eine frage
von anke schröder vom managed care
japanisches fernsehen zur booster
impfung gibt es signale waren die
booster impfung für die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen beziehungsweise unter 18
allgemein zugelassen wird
das wissen wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht ich bin mit den behörden im
gespräch
und hoffe dass wir das bald erreichen
können das ist ein großes problem weil
der impfschutz fehler zur bis
17-jährigen jetzt langsam also
abnimmt und wir müssen dieses problem
lösen da bin ich in gesprächen aber bis
jetzt kann ich da kann ich da nicht
anders kann das auch nicht vor geben in
dem sinne nicht kann nur durch gespräche
kann ich versuche das anzuregen das geht
hier im saal dabei susanne landwehr
deutsche vertrags zeitung ich habe eine
frage hat in lauterbach und zwar hat ihr
haus gerade eine ein entwurf
änderungsentwurf vorgelegt für die krone
ein reiseverordnung
und es geht darum dass pcr tests
gefordert werden wenn jemand aus einem
virus varianten gebiet einreist und das
betrifft ja viel auch die
transportbranche also lkw-fahrer die
grenzüberschreitend fahren binnenschiffe
die halt die grenzüberschreitend fahren
ist in dieser verordnung eine
ausnahmeregelung vorgesehen dass also
der verkehr laufen kann und wo anders
die lieferketten in der jetzigen
situation nicht unterbrochen werden oder
zerstört werden
schnelle antwort ist nein weil das
epidemiologische also nicht wirklich
sinnhaft wäre wenn wir hier eine
ausnahme machen würden aber natürlich
gilt für das transportgewerbe dass man
sich zweimal pro woche nur testen lassen
muss das halte ich aber auch für eine
zumutbare umsetzung jetzt habe ich eine
frage von gernot heller vom kurs von dem
büro herholz an herrn lauterbach einige
länder auch baden-württemberg wollen
eine erneute ausrufung der epidemischen
lage mit komplettem instrumenten
glaskasten inklusive lockdown bleibt das
eine option
ich nehme unter den rund verstehe ich
jetzt hier wurst in genau also es gibt
hier keine roten linien das habe ich ja
schon mehrfach gesagt aber auf der
anderen seite ist es so dass diese
position gestern bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nicht diskutiert wurde nicht vorgetragen
wurde und ich glaube mit den maßnahmen
die wir jetzt beschlossen haben können
wir das pandemische geschehen in den
nächsten wochen beherrschen ganz
grundsätzlich will man hier nichts
ausschließen wir erwägen alles was
notwendig wäre jetzt ist der punkt nicht
gegeben
andreas kühner ist der plan noch einmal
zu ihrer entscheidung gestern und ihrer
motivation so wie sie es jetzt
verteidigen hätten sie sich doch einfach
belassen können beim papier des
expertenrates vom sonntag hat sich für
sie die lage geändert oder warum haben
sie geglaubt dass es eines zusätzlichen
2 hier bedarf zu diesem zeitpunkt dessen
wirkungen sie hier abschätzen konnten
sie konnten jahr schätzen dass das wird
natürlich einen roms ausbildung also wie
gesagt ich habe ihn nicht mehr zu zu
finden als ich bereits gesagt habe das
ist ja die aufgabe des rk ii
empfehlungen auszusprechen das tun wir
sind sogar verpflichtet zu wenn sie
überrascht über die wirkungen diese
papiere
also
kann ich gar nichts zu sagen also ich
verfolge die nachrichten nicht so sehr
wie sie das vielleicht glauben insofern
habe ich dort keine einschätzung zu
ich mache nämlich meine arbeit und die
ist wissenschaftlich fundiert in erster
linie
jetzt habe ich noch ein zwei fragen von
patrick hollstein von apotheke adhoc
tiefer sich zusammen ist ein geht es um
die kosten der zusätzlich beschafften
dosen von herstellern oder aus dem
ausland ob frage ist ob das dem bund
mehr kostet als bislang
teil wurde ja schon vom
haushaltsausschuss freigegeben
und warum mussten sie das von ihrem
vorgänger bis zuletzt verteidigte er
rezept stoppen welche fehler wurden
gemacht wie geht es mit der gematik
weiter
zunächst also zu den
preisen die wir hier zahlen müssen die
preise sind geheim und dass daher kann
ich darüber nichts sagen
und zum zweiten
dass ihr rezept also es gab noch nicht
unerhebliche technische
umsetzungsprobleme die sind nicht
bewältigt und also an der an der
bewältigung dieser probleme arbeiten wir
intensiv ich konnte jetzt nicht sehen
dass in der person
notlage in der sich zum teil die praxen
derzeit befinden aber auch die kliniken
wir arbeiten ja an der belastungsgrenze
eine weitere belastung durch die noch
nicht komplett vorbereitete einführung
an dass er selbst sinnvoll sein könnte
dankeschön dafür jetzt setzen die
planung ich habe meine frage an den
minister der ethikrat hat jetzt in
sachen impfpflicht auch seine empfehlung
herausgegeben es war gestern auch team
aber der bund länder beratung das so
beschleunigt jetzt passieren wann
rechnen sie damit dass der bundestag
sich mit dem thema beschäftigt
das kann ich nicht wirklich beantworten
das kommt da waren wie schnell der
bundestag hier vorgeht ich persönlich
will nur zwei dinge sagen ich bin
grundsätzlich der überzeugung dass das
eine ethik frage ist die der bundestag
so beantworten sollte das aus der mitte
des parlaments
entsprechende vorschläge gemacht werden
sollten wo jeder abgeordnete dann nach
besten wissen und gewissen seine also
entscheidung trifft ohne fraktionszwang
das ist das erste was ich sagen möchte
und zum zweiten werden es solche anträge
geben wird dann also werde ich
sicherlich also einem antrag zustimmen
vielleicht auch an einem antrag
mitwirken der eine impfpflicht vorsieht
weil ich ohne eine impfpflicht
eine dauerhafte
bewegung immer wieder neu vorkommender
wählen also nicht sehen kann und daher
habe ich mich auch gefreut dass der
deutsche ethikrat
sich grundsätzlich für die prüfung einer
solchen pflicht ausspricht und in der
tendenz eher offen gegenübersteht ja
liebe zu schauen und zuschauer an dieser
stelle verlassen wir die pressekonferenz
in der bundespressekonferenz mit
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach und
lka chef lothar wieler bemerkenswert war
beide haben versucht die aufregung die
gestern entstanden ist rund um die
stellungnahme des robert-koch-instituts
ein wenig abzumildern
das ist mehr oder weniger gut gelungen
ich möchte es mal so ausdrücken es war
eine lange pressekonferenz wenn sie sich
details noch mal anschauen wollen
schauen sie gerne bei uns online rhein
und in die social media kanäle da haben
wir das für sie entsprechend noch mal
dokumentiert
naja und um die umsetzung der maßnahmen
geht es jetzt das ist aufgabe dann der
bundesländer und da liegen mittlerweile
auch einige reaktionen vor einige
bundesländer verschärfen die maßnahmen
schon jetzt dass es möglich rheinland
pfalz etwa da wird es schon ab
donnerstag keine zuschauer mehr geben
können bei großveranstaltungen und auch